have you ever wanted to see a large
group of grown men slap each other silly
to reach a gold briefcase WWE 2k 18 has
you covered with ladder matches one of
the match types that can now support up
to 8 superstars 2k 18 also sports
enhanced graphics and a giant roster of
over 180 playable characters from what
we've seen so far it looks like a lot of
fun for wrestling fans while regular
folks might not find it to be a big
enough leap over last year's edition
fortunately you get to decide for
yourself let's get to some gameplay of
WWE 2k 18
[Applause]
[Music]
guys this ladder match to be as exciting
as it will be dangerous if you're afraid
of heights I assure you this is not the
match for you
as I'd say these superstars look more
than ready to get this match started I'd
agree with that Cole and it sounds like
this arena is right there with them
they're absolutely electric right now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to
[Applause]
as we put the finishing touches on
preparations for this ladder match Byron
do you have a favorite well Michael
because this match is so very much
unlike your traditional match there's
almost no way to predict an outcome well
if I'm wrong boy will never let me hear
the end
and of course I'd like to encourage
anyone interested to check out
www.findingking.com oke you might think
twice about smoking
[Applause]
[Applause]
the ladders are ready guys as we wait to
get underway here for what will likely
be an amazing ladder match and we should
point out that the hazards involved in
this match are very real this is not
just about who can climb a ladder the
fastest as we'll soon see
[Applause]
and if you'd like to know more about the
effects of tobacco use I'd like to
encourage you to go to
www.michelintransport.com and
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm just
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
up next is the one we've been waiting
for guys the ladder match Michael this
matches the absolute definition of
high-risk high-reward especially
considering the height of those ladders
and what the winner gets to walk away
with at the end of this
[Music]
the ladders are set and so are we here
we go we've seen some amazing ladder
matches over the years and I'm willing
to bet this one will rank right up there
with some of the best a great Byron and
I'd say this match has what it takes to
be one of the special ones look he got
it with the ladder oh and look at him he
is hurt bad guys let's touch on Heath
Slater a bit as we get underway what can
the WWE Universe expect from this guy
something hanging over the ring ladders
made of steel it's not an accident that
ladder matches are considered some of
the most excruciating matches in WWE ty
Dillon jur starting to flounder some he
may have to start reevaluating his game
plan with so much on the line here in
this ladder match he has no choice but
to find a way to overcome this attack
guys by the looks of things I don't
think he expected his opponent to be as
motivated as he clearly is here tonight
skull on skull Roman reigns gathering
attention in a hurry here's look at this
man he's all business bo Dallas caught a
little off guard there but we all know
that he isn't afraid of a good fight
which is what we're seeing here well I
don't expect this to be the nail in the
coffin but it definitely is an ideal if
he wants to be able to climb the ladder
he's really gonna have to minimize the
effects of this attack you have to
possess a different type of focus to
punish an opponent like this swinging a
Miss that Willis strike one two and
three fight Dillinger is a force within
the ring all right
turns it around
here we go yeah okay look out he's got
it in his hands now not sure what
they're thinking he attacking his
opponent ten feet in the air
ladders are always a health hazard in
the workplace guys Roman reigns saw that
one coming
counters that one piece later doing a
great job turning that around what is it
that Bo Dallas can do here for a
physical and psychological revival of
this juncture looks to me like he's
starting to feel the pressure guys if he
takes much more punishment here guys I
don't think he'll be able to climb that
ladder there's just no way but if you're
counting him out now you haven't been
paying attention he has more result than
just about anybody on the roster and
what a reversal there for Bo Dallas
oh and he's still down Byron things
definitely aren't looking very good for
him right now
[Applause]
what is tide Dillinger's best strategy
at this point
he's always up for a challenge and
tonight is no different it's
make-or-break time here he absolutely
has to find a way to give back on the
offensive if he wants to win this match
what a ruthless onslaught to the back
and he's headed back in nobody controls
the pace of a match quite like this guy
he's not looking good here but what's
the boat Dazzler this might be it guys
yeah there's no way this match isn't
over after that one yeah let's hope he
can keep this kind of effort going
bottle that energy and he'd be a rich
BAM
sleeper slam that's what he was looking
for Michael oh man no way Jose really
needs to dig down deep ain't no stopping
him now too quick for him there there he
goes crashing to the floor he's taking a
long time to get up guys perhaps playing
a little possum here Cole we've got a
climber
[Applause]
here comes some Oh Joan oh this one is
over this might end badly
looks like Samoa Joe is fading a bed you
could bet this is not how we drew this
one up you call what impact wow I'm just
as surprised as you guys are and that's
the second time he's used that guy's and
probably not the last
he's not getting up you can't like his
chances right now
[Applause]
this is not good not where he wants to
be right now yeah you're not gonna win
many matches when you're down
Dillinger's terrifying when he's in a
groove like this oh boy he is rolling no
that's gonna leave a mark
watch out that might be enough momentum
is fully in the corner of Samoa Joe now
what should Roman reigns try to eat
differently at this stage to stay in
this thing and at this point yet they
wonder if he can recover from this
matches like this really have a way of
sapping your energy as it was the muscle
buster that's how you put an exclamation
point on the end of a match guys Heath
Slater has him in his sights nah man
what a hit knocked right off the apron
that one was packed with plenty of
malice he's got him on his heels and
shows no signs of letting up up up and
away he's so close he can probably taste
the victory right now nothing's set in
stone jump up throat side slam by Noah
way Jose that should do it
watch out it seems clearing the ladder
is more important at this point this
could go one of two ways we shall see
ill-advised move
going for it all here Oh perfectly done
that has got to be it oh man Roman
reigns doesn't even know where he is he
doesn't appear to be in a hurry to get
up here I just don't think he has it in
him anymore
the ax set begins now back to the ring
up and over the scoop slam there's some
good contact there by Bo Dallas he is a
one-man gang in there ouch
after a move like that he's gonna need
to see a chiropractor or spine
specialist whatever he's coupled with oh
here's his mullet Michael I think that
caught everybody in this arena off-guard
I guess he look out he's got his hands
on it
looking good might be in the results of
this attack on the back may be
catastrophic he's too quick from there
and a powerful forearm and a lethal
clothesline here we go back inside the
ring and Byron he's still down after
that one yeah that did some big-time
damage Michael he's delivering an old
fashioned butt-kickin right here ah the
reversal by schinsky Nakamura heads up
the ladder
here comes reigns if he could just pull
it down now right there for the taking
now Roman reigns picks up a strong
victory
[Applause]
you